what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest episode of the attack
on titan final season
this episode was called assassin's
bullet and
true to its name there was a major death
and the huge
twist that zeke is actually still alive
so make sure to stay tuned for that
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
titan videos they want to keep them
coming then the best thing to do
is warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on time
fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and while you wait for the
next
insane episode to drop feel free to
check out our growing attack on time
playlist where we got videos about all
the titan shifters and their powers all
the ackermans and their powers the
titans ranked from weakest to strongest
and much more link to that
is in the description now without
further ado let's jump into it
so this episode starts with aaron's
titan holding the helpless jaw titan
reiner transformed into his very human
looking titan transformation after
hearing the cries
of falco and gabby again i believe that
this weird partial transformation
is the result of his weak will to live
and to fight
that's usually what it takes to
transform and reiner made it clear that
he wanted to die
he wouldn't have even been able to
transform if gaby and falco didn't give
him a push
that let him take on this incomplete
transformation anyways reiner runs to
attack aaron's titan
and gets beaten back he falls and he's
in no condition to battle anymore
however he did manage
to rescue porco's titan now you might
think that this is a good opportunity to
take down reiner and porco at once for
aaron and mikasa but aaron says i quote
the fight is
over we're out of strength end quote and
he also mentions he can't kill reiner
now aaron definitely had the chance to
take the jaw titan power if you ask me
so let me know why you think he didn't
do you think he just played with him too
long or do you think he didn't take the
power on purpose
it's possible that another titan power
would be too much too
soon for him since he already has three
inside of him now
the attack titan the founding titan and
now the warhammer titan 2.
and do you think he was actually
completely out of steam
and strength or did he want to spare
reiner since he used to be his friend to
me it definitely seemed like aaron had
no interest in killing reiner and he
even said bye to him as if he was
partying with a friend but it's possible
he was also in no position to take his
power because he wasted too much of it
and wouldn't be able to transform again
since he was the first person to
transform and he did transform three
times already
this whole episode we got gabby who
turns out to be the assassin
being angry and chasing after the
airship she wants revenge
she wants to go down fighting she has
drive and passion
and a bunch of energy honestly she's
very similar to how aaron was
when he was younger except her hatred
and drive is directed towards taking out
the island aldians
who she sees as devils while kid aaron
was focused on taking out the titans
from our perspective now it's easier to
see how ridiculous gabby is behaving
because we have a more complete picture
of what's going on while with aaron we
didn't know the truth about titans and
how they came to be
and so we didn't realize immediately how
pointless aaron's hatred geared towards
mindless titans who were
secretly aldians and victims of marlene
cruelty was
but yeah let's move on from angry gabby
now to
aaron and mikasa who hop aboard the
airship aaron is no longer as clearly
energetic and strong driven as
gabby is because that insane level of
energy and drive can only come when you
view yourself as the pure hero
and your opponent as the pure villain
with no gray area in between for aaron
he's not so idealistic anymore he
knows that reiner isn't the bad guy he's
just a guy who attacked him and his
people because he thought it was the
right thing to do
and now he attacked them back because he
thinks it's the right thing to do for
him and his people
the people of paradise island even as he
pursues his agenda
aaron knows that he is killing innocent
people and thus he no longer has that
twinkle
in the eye and high hopes of someone
like gabby rather he has a lifeless
tortured face
now as levi will point out even as he
continues marching forward with his plan
this is a very powerful moment where
armin is clearly upset with aaron after
all aaron unilaterally
aka by himself decided he would leave
paradise island and undertake this whole
operation
even if levi hunji armin and the rest
were against it because of him
the rest had to come because aaron and
the founding titan are too valuable to
fall in the hands of the marlians and
thus aaron forced them to come here and
the deaths that took place can thus all
be blamed on him
if you look at it in that way armin
probably blames aaron for turning him
into a killer of innocent people too
which he became when he used the
colostine explosion to wipe out the
ships
dock and land thus you get it when he's
not overjoyed to see aaron but even
though he probably hates what he's done
and aaron for making him do it he is
still aaron's friend and reaches his
hand out to aaron
and aaron takes it it's a small but
extremely powerful moment that says to
me
i hate what you did but you're still my
friend and i won't turn my back on you
levi isn't quite so forgiving levi kicks
aaron in the face and sends him fly and
calls him a filthy sight to behold
he says aaron has such a kickable face
which is pretty hilarious despite the
seriousness of the tone right now
this is where he says aaron's face
reminds him of the people he saw in the
underground who to me represents sad
human beings with little room for naive
hope
and ideals and aaron in his view had to
become such a sad person despite how
hopeful and idealistic he was in the
past
he feels like it's killed or be killed
and he had to do stuff he wasn't proud
of and stuff that even tortured him
because he thinks it's the only way to
save his people
levi said he never thought he'd see
aaron have that face
but he does because aaron has in a way
sacrificed his soul
sold it to the devil in order to give
his people a fighting chance
many times in this episode people will
blame aaron for the deaths that took
place but the truth is
if aaron stayed a sitting duck the fast
advancing marlene technology along with
all of their titan powers
could have been used to wipe them out on
the island rather than seeing aaron as
the cause of the survey core deaths one
might argue aaron is the reason the rest
survived but that is all up for debate
we're told that everything went
according to aaron's plan there has been
six casualties so far
but flocc and the others are more
idealistic like gabby in the sense that
they see things in very binary terms
they are really happy because they
killed way more of the enemy than they
lost
and they viewed this battle as a
glorious victory for the new eldian
empire sasha jean and connie though are
more mature in their view and don't get
excited they wonder how many more
battles will there be
how many more people will die they know
that they didn't just kill the enemy but
real complex human beings
nonetheless connie is glad glad that
they three survived
because sasha and gene are special to
him even though he probably doesn't want
to admit it
he's a lot like aaron he has people who
are special to him and they take
priority over the others
who's to say how many people connie
would be willing to sacrifice
if it means he could save sasha while
connie is hugging them sasha warmly
touches connie's arm suggesting that
there might be shared feelings between
the two that aren't totally platonic
sasha our potato girl meme who is always
good for some comedic relief moments
comments that she wants to eat then we
jump to gabby who was spared because
sasha didn't want to kill a child
sasha had the chance to kill her but she
only killed the merlion soldiers
who showed gabby kindness gabby is mad
about those soldiers dying
and zofia and udo dying since this is
her home
where the people she cares about live
and aaron attacked it
she watched zeke who she cared a lot
about and viewed as her captain
and hero die while she was powerless to
help we may well be thinking right now
that aaron felt the exact same way
when reiner attacked him and the smiling
titan is mom and falco brings up exactly
that he says this was revenge because
marlei attacked them
but gaby doesn't care she didn't see
that and neither did falco so she
refuses to be swayed by it
besides she's been brainwashed to
believe that the island devils threaten
peace
they are cruel devils who've always
deserved to die they are irredeemable in
her view
they can't be good they're nothing like
the aldeans on the continent
this is the easy way to look at things
for gabby gabby must know as falco does
deep down that what she's saying isn't
true but she won't accept it because she
needs a scapegoat
she needs something and someone to
direct all her feelings of injustice and
hatred toward
and the island devils the epitome of
pure evil in her mind
are the perfect target gabby spots the
old timer hanging from the ship
he could have shot her like sasha could
have but he didn't because she's a kid
and so she shot and killed him
this guy was an extra not really someone
we are emotionally invested in but he
serves to show that this world in attack
on titan is kill or be killed and if you
show mercy
you have to be prepared to be killed as
a result gabby wants falco to tell
everyone she fought to the end and she
wants the rest of them to carry on her
will
as she prepares to get aboard the
airship but falco refuses to let her go
alone he grabs on and they leave
colt falco's brother to freak out on the
ground
sasha a contender for best girl hears
something and then gabby appears
and shoots sasha shoots our potato girl
this is the first big death on the
survey core side this season
and why did it happen because sasha
spared gabby
as they say the good die young and then
there's that batman quote you either die
a hero
or you live long enough to see yourself
become a villain and sasha died pure
she refused to compromise her morals
refused to kill a child and she died as
a result
aaron who had no such hangups was
willing to become a villain to save his
people and he is still alive
it suggested that the world of attack on
titan will inevitably corrupt you
if you stay in it long enough and i
can't describe how tragic it is to see
our precious potato girl die
it's horrible and it's horrible seeing
connie deal with it who
obviously loved her more than anything
and it also symbolizes how there's no
room in this series anymore
for comedic relief and lighthearted
moments it's just darkness now and right
now it seems like it's going to swallow
up everyone
falco ends up tackling gabby in an
attempt to save her which stops her from
possibly killing jean as well the two
kids get beaten up bad because they are
the enemy and they just shot one of
their own
as she's dying sasha thinks of food she
thinks of food until the very
end while gene needs to figure out what
to do with the enemy kids
some suggest throwing them out of the
plane while he ends up tying them up
and bringing them to where aaron and
levi are in the meantime we jump to peak
who remembers that she saw the soldier
who led them to the trap before
she was a soldier really devoted to zeke
as we later figure out this was yell
enough and she wore a fake
beard yeah they probably should have
gotten someone with an actual beard but
whatever
then we find out in epic fashion that
zeke is
actually alive as gabby and falco see
him
gabby wonders why zeke let them capture
him but hunji reveals that this was
actually
all zeke's plan what a twist it must be
for these guys and for us
and it's definitely one of the biggest
twists in attack on titan and that's
saying a lot for a series like this
the basement reveal was still probably
the craziest of all
but this is up there zeke rather than
siding with falco and gabby simply
refers to them as miscalculations
levi and zeke even though they are sort
of on the same side now
still don't get along so let's not get
ahead of ourselves
because yaluna failed to keep the kart
and jaws trapped zeke had to improvise
and throw more rocks than planned
thus killing more people than planned
levi calls zeke a hairball which is
pretty funny i love the back and forth
between these two
and zeke tells levi to stop glaring at
him or he'll pee his pants
definitely not something you expected to
hear from marley's strongest warrior
levi clearly wants to kill zeke badly
but he knows it's not the time for that
and says he'll save the best bite for
last so the rivalry between them goes on
but there is a temporary truce
apparently aaron with this mission
bought paradise island time and now
through zeke they have a royal blooded
titan and when the founding titan user
namely aaron makes contact with a
royal-blooded titan meaning zeke
aaron should be able to unlock the
complete powers of the founding titan
and he won't be limited by carl fritz's
pacifist ideology this means aaron will
be able to wake up to tens of millions
of colossal titans and control them
he'll be able to rewrite ldn memories
and he'll be able to change the body
compositions of all aldeans among other
things
giving him pretty much god-like powers
on top of all that
aaron also managed to get the warhammer
titan power
so now it's clear that him coming into
contact with zeke
was the most important part of the plan
and whether they got the jaw titan armor
titan
wasn't actually that important people
mentioned the lives that were sacrificed
to get aaron back but again you could
say everyone's life would have been
sacrificed if he didn't do this
eventually
now much of marlene technology has been
destroyed and they have the rumbling of
the colossal
titans they can use if the merlions try
anything aaron has definitely increased
the likelihood of island ld and survival
through this mission but let me know
your thoughts do you blame aaron for the
deaths that happened including sasha's
or do you think aaron had to do it
anyways connie comes and confirms the
really tragic truth that sasha is dead
he cries armin cries mikasa cries and
aaron two
is crushed her last word was meat
she tried to keep them laughing right
until the end but she won't be able to
do that anymore
again symbolizing a shift in the series
to a much darker tone
where there is even less space for
comedic relief like the kind sasha
always offered us
through the flashback we see that sasha
was a very positive optimistic person
but as i said
in the attack on titan world so far it
seems like the good pure ones die young
while the others get corrupted and
arguably even become villains
if you ask the marleans our protagonist
aaron has just become the biggest
worst villain in the world again people
even blame sasha's death on aaron saying
she only died because aaron dragged the
scouts into this but no one says that he
may
have saved everyone else it wasn't an
easy decision for aaron but as the
preview of the next episode
says unable to change the past they must
continue down the one before them
if you haven't read the manga and didn't
see the death coming let me know how
sasha's death hits you
let me know how zeke being alive and
being behind the whole thing hit you
and let me know what you think about
aaron and his actions
also how do you feel about gabby who
murdered our precious potato girl
after she was spared multiple times i'd
love to hear your thoughts on all of
these things
and also your thoughts on this
particular episode as a whole
the next episode preview shows that we
will have some flashback moments
of what happened during the time skip so
we will still
be able to appreciate sasha's wonderful
character although it will have a tragic
spin on it because we'll know that she
is destined to die
during this attack the episode is called
brave
volunteers and that is it for this one a
very tragic one with multiple crazy
twists
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
titan episode reviews
and want to keep them coming every week
then the best thing you can do is
warhammer smash
that like button if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos
and while you wait for the next insane
episode to drop
feel free to check out our growing
attack on titan playlist where we got
videos about all the titan shifters and
their powers
all the ackermans and their powers the
titans ranked from weakest to strongest
and much more linked to that is in the
description
and until next time see us space cowboys
and rest in peace sasha
you